Everyone!
Hello!
Hello, hello, hello!
Hello, hello!
How do I move you around on the collab thing?
Oh, you go to the bottom, like, you know, at the bottom,
right?
It says the, you click on that and then there's, like, you
control the position.
Yeah, yeah.
I gotta make you small.
I actually gotta make both of us smaller.
Give me a sec.
Yeah.
Oh, that's not the right one.
Okay, I think this is where we're small.
No, that's not us when we're smaller.
I think, no, that's not us when we're smaller.
I'll eventually find the small version.
I think it's, oh, there we go.
There we go.
Now we're smaller here.
Now we're a little smaller because we won't make sure we
don't cover.
Actually, I don't know.
Should I be a bit bigger?
Let's make it, let's do that.
It's okay.
We gotta see ourselves.
Hello, everyone.
Hello, hello.
Welcome.
Hello, hello, everybody.
Welcome to Girls Frontline 2.
you excited to know if you ever played this game before no
no i actually haven't oh it's your first oh don't worry
you're gonna have a good time there's like this there's one
feature in this game that i love a lot and there's one
feature but huge shout out and thank you to the sponsor
girls for line two for sponsoring us today because it's
their first year anniversary Dang!
Yeah!
Yes, yeah, it's their anniversary today.
And for those who don't know, if you guys link your accounts
right now, to your Twitch account right now, to your Girl's
Front Line 2 account, we do have Twitch drops.
So if you watch your streams, you're eligible for Twitch
drops at the moment.
So make sure to link your account.
Make sure to link your account to Twitch so you can have
access to all the in-game rewards.
And also, in 25 minutes, a giveaway for Girls Frontline 2
Codes.
Yes, and what is in those codes, Snuffy.
Oh.
You got this.
Okay, the rewards?
Yeah, 100 collapse pieces.
Whoa!
Free stuff!
5,000 Sardis gold.
Yeah!
Yeah, Sardis?
Sardis?
I start.
2,000 combat reports.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, so if you guys get picked, so we're giving away 10
codes in total.
So each of us has five.
So if, you know, if you guys want to up your chances, you
can enter both our giveaways at the same time.
So we're going to be giving away 10 codes in total, five
from each of us.
And if you get the code, you're eligible to win all of
these, basically.
But yeah, I'm really excited to do this sponsor stream with
Snuffy.
There's a lot to expect for the first year anniversary.
Are we looking forward to seeing today for the first year
anniversary?
Me or like the chat?
Or just like, just for what to expect, you know, like the
130 paws, like all that stuff, all the free stuff.
I think that's always what people expect from a good
anniversary is.
What's the freebies?
What can we get?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And what can we get, Snuffy?
What are the freebies?
You got this, I believe.
Why do you keep asking the person who's never played this
game?
I'm trying to help you, you know, I'm trying to guide you
into all this.
I'm just trying to be a very good teacher.
I'm like reading my menu right now.
I have delicious segments, my login rewards.
Okay, okay, so for the first year anniversary, there are
over 130 plus, 13,000 collapsed pieces.
Two haas, Dragon Chef, as well as Springfield's Enjoy the
Fragrance outfits.
And they are all for free.
And that's the best part.
Yeah, the freebies that you're going to get on the first
anniversary event.
We're also going to have a new event that's going to start
today, actually.
Which starts today.
Happy Thanksgiving.
Deep oblivion.
We have a part two on December 18th.
And there's also another event that's going to start today.
It's intertwined us.
Who are the new dolls, Snuffy?
The new dolls?
Is that what the characters are called?
Yeah, yeah, they're dolls.
They're like not real.
They're real to them, but they're real to us, but...
They're real to us, guys.
They're real to us.
We have Lava?
Lava?
The electric attribute Sentinel doll that converts excess
stability damage to electric damage.
Dang.
And there's another one, too, which is Lena.
yeah they're both electric attribute support dolls this one
can generate large amounts of voltage terrain tiles which in
intrigues me a little bit because i don't know quite what
that is yeah so so yeah so it's like it's like part of the
gameplay so they all have like different type advantages and
stuff so that's why that's what like the tiles are like you
know the movement and stuff is the tiles um because it's
like a strategy game and my chat loves like making fun in
strategy games uh but the thing i love about this game is
that there's a thing called auto and when i click it it
doesn't matter how good i am at strategy i i just win when i
click the auto button anyway we want to make want to let you
guys know that these accounts are temporarily provided by
the official hika team so they're you guys will be like wow
joki you You willed a lot for this account.
They weren't temporarily provided.
They were temporarily provided by them.
So it's not my official account.
Just so you guys know.
Because like I know Klu-Kai in here is gonna.
I know like whenever they temporarily provide me an account.
Klu-Kai is like the most jacked character in this game.
She's like the main character in this game.
And it's always whoever whichever dev like owns this
account.
I was Klukei, which is great because there is a Klukei event
here and like we're that we're all gonna enjoy today Yes,
he's all we need All right, before we begin to know yeah, I
want to know what character I have like I'm now you're
you're making me I think it's Klukei.
I think it's I think it's Klukei Klukei, it's I swear to
God.
I like okay, there was one moment where So you can marry
your dolls Um, yeah, you can get married to them and I
wanted to like remove the ring from Klu-Kai because I want
to marry someone else and And then she crashed my game for
40 minutes.
I couldn't I had to restart my PC Because I was like, I'm
sorry.
I didn't mean it.
I'm sorry Klu-Kai like sequins.
Yeah, it was actual It was deserved because I was just like
I wanted to marry a different doll and then and And the
Klukei crashed my PC and I had to restart my entire stream
during a sponsor too.
Oh my.
Well, let's hope that doesn't happen.
Don't divorce anybody today.
Don't divorce.
Don't do that.
Klukei, don't do that to Klukei.
She's the only one that can mess with your PC.
She's the only one.
Anyway, so we have, before we start, we actually have like a
little segment that they wanted us to do.
What was it again, Snuffy?
Are you ready for the Are you ready for the challenge?
I'm so nervous now How are you nervous?
We just It's just a challenge It's a small little challenge
Hold on, I don't turn my game down Oh, okay Don't be so
nervous Do we have the voice line?
Where do I see my game?
Oh, to see your character You go to I think was uh it's on
the refitting room you go to the refitting room and then oh
guys okay um yeah okay so a clue cut okay clue cut is not
this devs this is not the devs favorite from one dude i have
like a swimsuit yeah me too me too i i do too all right so
before we begin we have this little challenge that we got we
gotta do snuffy i'm pulling it up Where is it?
Okay, okay, okay.
All right, so we have a little wheel that we have to do, and
it's called the Expression Wheel Imitation Challenge.
So we gotta spin a wheel, and we gotta see if we can imitate
the expression.
You first.
Oh my God.
As the senior here of sponsor streams, I nominate Snuffy to
go first.
Wait, I'm trying to find the characters.
They're so cute.
My team is so cute.
I'm trying to find mine.
Where's Lina?
Do I have the characters?
Do I have them?
I'm pretty sure we have them, right?
Okay, I'm trying to find.
Do I have to help me, like, navigate if I have more?
Oh, no.
I don't know.
I'm...
Wait, oh, there's CluKai.
I found CluKai.
Oh, my God.
I have swimsuit, CluKai.
Oh, wait.
I think I have swimsuit glu kai too.
Oh my god.
Wait, I don't think we have Lina.
Or...
Yeah, I don't have the new ones.
Wait, do we have to pull her?
Oh that's okay, we can pull her.
We can pull her right now.
I don't know.
What if I don't get lucky though?
Okay, you have to do the ones you pull.
Okay wait, wait.
I...
Okay, you pull for Lina.
I'm gonna do the one you pull.
Okay, I'm gonna...
and then you can see it Lina and Lava here.
Oh, okay, so they each have their own band.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, I don't have any dollars.
Wait, wait.
What do you mean?
I do.
You're just giving me money.
You're broke.
That is, what do you not have money?
What do you mean?
What does I need 10 of these tokens?
Yeah, I have 10 of them.
How much?
What happened?
Oh, I have plenty.
Oh, yeah, I was going to.
say what happened okay you gotta do a pull okay i bet who am
i doing did you say yeah i got i got lever you get lena oh
okay okay okay wait actually wait actually let me see wait
actually i think you're a lever and i'm a lena i was gonna
say yeah yeah no i'm a i'm a lean lena yeah i'm a lena all
right all right okay you guys ready it's like you guys sorry
you yeah chow are you ready too all right three two one pull
Oh, yeah, okay, so this is cool.
I've never played this game before, so I'm like I didn't
know the gravity of this girl I didn't get it.
Oh, this is cute.
I didn't get it.
How do you know if it's a good pool?
When you open a door and it glows So it glows purple.
That's not it has to be gold I mean, I got one though.
Yeah, but it's not her.
All right.
Dang.
Oh, oh yeah.
Okay.
I didn't get her.
It's purple.
I guess.
Some stupid-ass guns.
I got Lutara.
Dang.
I got...
What?
Who's here?
I got...
Oh, I got the money girl.
I forgot.
I didn't remember her.
She just loves money.
There's a lot of guns.
I know, that's what I'm saying.
Oh, I got a medic.
I mean, her idea of medic is just putting a band-aid over
her wounds, but that's okay.
But...
Don't worry.
A band-aid will solve...
we'll solve all the blood all right it's okay i have five
more times to pull her it should work did you get it yet no
no no that's okay it's okay one of us we can i believe i
need to be gold right not purple gold okay i'm skipping it's
just guys all i got was guns all right well it's okay i
still have four more times to pull her how many times are
you pull already this This is my fourth tab.
I'm about to do my third pool.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay, here, here, here, here.
I didn't get it.
Come on, do something, do something special.
I've got more guns!
How do I keep getting guns?
I...
Oops, all guns.
We got this build.
Damn it!
All right.
Oh, wait, this character is actually stupid.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Gold, I got gold, I got gold!
Okay.
It's not gonna be the banner.
Don't say that!
That's messed up!
We have to progress in this stream!
Oh!
Wait, how are you going to do the challenge when we don't
have it?
Wait, I think that's her.
Wait, no way.
I got her.
Fifth pull.
Fifth try.
Yeah, I did it.
I got her.
I got five or six pulls.
Okay, oh, I'm better.
I got five tries.
Let's stream a look.
Yeah, boy.
You're streaming, too.
What do you mean?
This is pre-recorded.
I just know what you're going to say.
Pre-recorded chat.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I actually took me, like, 50 pulls, and I took the one
recording that had it in the least amount of tries.
That's right, yeah.
I'm gonna clip through this.
Okay, come on, come on.
This is, like, six pulls.
What if I, what if it takes me 20 pulls to get it?
What if I get to the penny?
Okay, you know what?
I'm so confident that I'm going to pull for it, Lava, as
well.
Whoa!
That one, I'm being raced.
I only got guns that time.
I'm going to pull for her, too.
What if I use up all the money?
that the dev gave me no you have more you have like the
bonus money bonus you have yeah you have the bonus money you
know that one warrior says two million gems that's the bonus
money that you can't run out you're gonna hit penny dude
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna get wait she's doing like Wait,
wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
This is it.
Is it gold?
You're 10th floor.
This was gold.
This is it.
Wait, this is going to be it.
You get it?
Chat, is this it?
Is this it?
What do you mean?
You already forgot what she looked like?
Wait, her voice line.
Wait, is this her?
Wait, this isn't her.
Wait, no, this is her.
No, boy.
This is her.
She's cool.
She has a cool scar.
I like that.
She's seen things.
Okay, I think we both need, like, oh my god, I got, oh my
god, I messed up the pity.
I got some other girl.
I'm trying to pull for your character.
Dang.
Okay, I give up.
It's okay.
All right, now we can do the wheel challenge.
All right, I'm pulling up the wheel again.
All right, I'm going to the fitting room.
Where is...
I say here we don't it's okay snuffy has the other one I
have mine I lost the 50-50 so it required me to do like
another set of pulls and I don't I'm not that is not true it
did not require you to do that what is her voice line anyway
what does she say how do you get her to say stuff you poke
her oh wait she's just she's just like
introduction how do you get her voice lines i guess like
should we just pretend like this is what this character is
what they existed like we roleplay okay so you go to the
okay so yeah i was like speak so i poked it and all she did
was go uh uh yeah oh it's a dormitory okay so this is my um
you click the couch go to your character and you click the
okay and then guys guys it just automatically took me to her
bed oh my god i didn't realize i would be like watching her
sleep yeah yeah so you could go to examining and then you
can you can poke her and talk to her see look look she's
talking it's not it's not she's not talking she's breathing
These are going to be great impressions.
And then you go to see what they...
Oh, this is my favorite part.
This is the best part about this game.
So you see the top right.
And then, okay, go to Deep City.
And then go to the top right and click the camera.
What?
Camera?
Oh.
The top right, you see the camera icon.
Oh, whoa.
Yeah, you get to see her amazing room.
That's why it's the best part.
room guys are the rooms like unique yeah yeah yeah yeah you
get to see it like that's the point of the camera snuffy so
you can see her her room her hobbies yeah yeah her hobbies
her rooms and like nothing else uh you can also zoom in on
the cute plushies that are displayed in her brew
you know you zoom in on her homework notes do you see that
look at her notes for her class yeah yeah and she's got a
bookie look at that and like oh what did she write here what
did she yeah yeah see all the fun things you can do in her
room snuffy you're just looking at around her room right
nothing else of course i was following your guidance yeah
yeah nothing yeah that's good that's good okay so to see the
voice lines You go to the archive and then there's voice and
then you can see what she says.
Okay.
And then there's one where she's like, so that's how you do
it.
Oh, they speak.
They speak Japanese in mine.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, God.
I mean, we're just repeating in English.
All right.
Are you ready to spin the wheel?
Oh.
Oh my god, you okay, you go first.
Wait, no, you go first.
I nominate, as the senior here, I nominate you to go first.
The senior in what sense that you've played this game
before?
Yes, exactly.
As someone has been sponsored by Girls Frontline 2, thank
you again for the sponsor.
I nominate a snuffy to go first.
Spin the wheel.
Okay, let me pull up my wheel.
The special wheel.
nervous shot oh my god okay what
did you get oh spinning yeah i got i got it gives me a
little emoji yeah come on come on do it what's emoji is it
it looks very mischievous oh i know i know this one hold on
i'll post it that one what how do i know which voice line
this is i just just play a voice and see if it if it
replicates oh wait wait oh wait that's that's uh lena oh
does that mean it's you yeah no no no that means you have
okay this is how she said she's like oh yeah she did just
that he's like i'm cracking myself up
Wait, do I, okay, so I should do your character or my
character.
We're supposed to have, we're both supposed to have both
characters, but like, I gave up.
Okay, I'll spin again.
Let me spin again.
I lost my, I lost my 50-50, so I gave up pulling the other
character.
Okay, I'm gonna do that.
Let me, let me see if I can spin and get my character.
Okay.
I believe.
Oh yeah, okay, okay, okay.
Ooh, I got winky, winky face.
Winky face.
What's like a good thing she says?
Like I said, winky face and you've never winked.
Cherish the rest of your life.
Why would she say that?
She's just like, surprised.
Don't want me to cherish the rest of my life?
That's it.
Okay, okay.
Surprise.
Why did you even wink?
Why did you just close both eyes?
You like just closed, that's blinking.
Why did you just blink?
Just pretend like, okay, wait, wait, wait, I gotta, I gotta
go.
You didn't even wink.
Oh, surprise.
He has covers your eyes.
Yeah, I was winking, you couldn't tell.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, that's a great wink you got there.
All right, all right, my turn.
I mean, technically, I technically I did mine because I did
yours.
No, that was you were you were you were being my senpai and
you were showing me all of them.
I just just teaching you the ways I gave you a little free.
Oh, I got the same one that you got.
I got the wiki face.
Yeah, the wiki face.
Wait, what was the line?
I'll do it again, too.
Oh, I got it.
It was like surprise.
Yeah, I was like, surprise.
Oh, my God.
I like that.
Very good.
Hold on.
How many times have we got to spin it?
Let me spin it again.
You want to do one more?
I got it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let me spin it again.
You chose to do one more.
Oh.
What do you get?
I got really close to the really, like, angry looking one,
but I got winky face again, so I'm going to do the angry
one.
I just, like, I do need a new voice line for it.
Let's see.
What?
Wait, that's it?
No, no, no.
It's just really long.
What?
Is that really what?
That's a whole Are you okay?
Okay, I'm going to do this one.
You scared me.
I had no idea you were there, Commander.
Was that too fake?
Sorry about that.
I'll try to be more convincing next time.
Bro, I thought you were supposed to be angry.
That's why she's angry.
She is.
She's very catty.
That's how you were.
That's like, that's not angry.
You're not angry.
No, she uses the tilde in almost all of her life.
Yeah, she is.
Okay.
All right, let's head out.
Let's head out.
I don't want to be in a room anymore.
No, no, no, no.
You got to do another one.
No, no, it's too late.
We got to move on.
We have a lot to cover, guys.
We have a lot.
You chose to do a second one, Stuffy.
I was just like, well, okay.
You want to do a second one?
That was your choice.
That's true.
Alright, before, oh wait, that is snuffy.
You see what time it is?
Oh.
Starts with a G.
It's time for?
It starts with a G.
Go Minasari.
I don't know.
Give away.
What am I saying?
Yeah, give away!
It's giveaway time.
Giveaway time.
Dude, what?
What are we giving away again, Doki?
We are giving away five codes from each of us.
And in each of the codes comes with a hundred class pieces,
5,000 Sardis Gold, and 2,000 combat reports.
So you can win, technically you can win 10 from both of us
in total.
So we're going to do a little giveaway.
And each person, the person that wins the giveaway will be.
contacted by our mods uh to receive a code i assume our mods
right like yeah yeah yeah please do not listen to any
strangers in your chat yeah just make sure they have the
they have the the the little the cog just make sure they
have the cog verify that it is staff on one of our channels
please yeah let me i can log in for me yeah make sure just
make sure it's the actual staff so um to enter It is Let me
grab the keyword Oh yeah Let me get mine started Yeah yeah
yeah yeah Alright so the keyword to enter the giveaway Is
I'll put it up on the screen as well for everyone Let me
Should we run them at the same time Should you do yours
first and then mine?
Yeah I think we I mean it happens on both our chats So it
should be fine So this is the giveaway code i think it
should be fine all right you can enter now on my chat i
don't know what if stuffy said set it up oh my god that was
so like okay enter now it's just like not even a countdown
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm just like i mean i did mine already
okay chat hold up hold the phone hold the phone since i did
this i had this all prepared and then it's like and then
it's what when it comes down to it i ain't got no clue you
know make sure oh can i enter my own oh my god i can enter
my what if i no no guys i'm gonna enter my own giveaway oh
my god i'm in it okay okay what if i win my own giveaway
guys it's not fair
This will be...
Chat, I think this is going to be ours.
I hope I can run this correctly.
Please trust in me.
I believe you.
This is what you're going to use to join the raffle.
And I think if I do this...
No, guys, don't worry.
It's not going to be rigged.
Join the raffle on my chat, too.
Also...
If you guys want a chance to get those rewards.
Yeah, and also, guys, make sure to click the link pinned in
our chats or on our panels.
the game and try it out for yourself too remember there is a
lot of free stuff going on right now for the first year
anniversary so yeah and also you gotta have an account to
claim these over rewards so you know you might as well like
you might as well so we're gonna have to give away running
uh running for another uh two minutes two to three minutes
and then we'll pull up the winners guys here's the i'm
entering it again i'm entering my giveaway again uh what If
you win, I'm gonna, that's gonna be the funniest thing.
There's no way.
Dude, that takes so much sauce.
Wait, what?
What?
I was, like, max leveling my character.
You're max?
When you were max leveling while we were setting up the
kill?
I don't know how to play this game.
I don't want to fail the mission.
All right.
So, I, okay, so the mod on my end, I will contact you would
be Silent Bandito, by the way.
If you have someone being like, I am Doki's mod, please give
me your information.
That is not the mod.
The mod is Silent Bandito.
Just so you guys know.
You don't accidentally.
That would be the same, I think.
Don't just so you guys know.
In case you accidentally give your...
The mods will not be asking for your information.
They will just be giving you a code.
Just so you guys know.
Do not give your information out.
You're just going to get a code if you're...
Yeah, yeah.
Do not give your...
And you're the mod and if you want to give your information
to the mod that's on you like if the If you want you you can
if you want but like I feel safer if the mods have all my
login information Yeah, yeah, it's to be like, hey, here's
my here's my girl's front line to information.
Can you claim the code for me?
Can I do my dailies?
Yeah, can you do my dailies as well?
All right, um, I would do the giveaway first and then snuffy
actually I mean, I feel like we could do the giveaway
together since, since like, um, I feel like it doesn't
really matter.
I did mine too.
What do you mean?
Oh, you already did your giveaway?
You already, you said, wait, you already chose the winners?
Oh, oh, no, I don't know.
I meant choose it at the same time.
Yeah, it's fine because like it's each our own chats.
All right, all right, I'm choosing winner.
Mike, congratulations, Mike.
You were first winner.
Did it pop up?
My bot was like, nobody entered.
The code is for me.
The code is actually for me.
The way you're doing it, did you give away.
You were, stuffy, you were busy.
Very lovely, I'm your character stuff for great.
Yeah, you give away.
It was working good, and then he gave up.
And then he gave up.
Let's see.
All right, all right, I guess I'll re-roll the second guy.
Oh, wait, you're gonna re-roll?
I'm Mike, congratulations on winning the second giveaway
code.
Are you okay?
Are you?
Yeah, I'm just, I'm bad at the bots.
Oh, here we go, wait, wait.
Weed?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
There's so many different raffle commands.
Why?
I need to switch bots, dude.
This is, this is.
Oh, wait, two Mike's won.
Oh, yeah, I got Sid in the mic and Mike's seat.
Oh, yeah, you should have changed your name to Mike's, guys.
All right.
Gerald!
Wait.
Gerald, congratulations.
Second Mike has won the giveaway.
Okay, try again, right, guys?
Right?
I'm already on the third winner.
Wait, how many do you got to give out?
Oh, my God.
Five, what do you mean?
We have five bones eaten.
This is gonna work, this is gonna work.
Okay, this is gonna work.
What do you mean?
This is totally gonna work.
All right, two more guys.
John, congratulations, John.
You just have somebody win your raffle.
It's just named John.
John Raffle winner, come on down.
He has a last name, but like, just because like I'm tight
with John, okay?
Me and this chatter, we on a first name basis.
Yeah, I'm on a first name basis with all my chatters.
I don't know what you're doing, Snuffy.
Okay, chat, introduce yourself.
Give your first name, last name.
Where were you born?
Your mother's maiden name.
This is all necessary for the raffle.
Yeah, that's all necessary.
Make sure we know your mother's maiden name, too, for the
raffle as well.
But only on Snuffy's side, apparently.
We need that extra verification.
No, your social security isn't needed.
verification she not she needs all your information your
finger though oh yeah yeah for you're gonna fucking clone
like make sure you analyze their fingerprint to log on to
their phone too yeah yeah alright okay I'll wait till you
get your first giveaway winner before I get through my last
one I think it's about to end oh my god somebody won oh my
god what's his name craters craters Bro, how come my gap,
all the people in my side are like actual names and then
you're like, crater.
Yeah, craters.
Craters, congratulations, craters.
Yay.
Oh, yay.
I'm so happy it works.
Okay, I'm going to start another one, you guys.
Are you ready for Raffle number two?
Bam, bam, bam, bam.
We have five to go through.
Doki's already done like four.
I learned four, so you have four more.
There's another one.
Continue to enter.
You guys know explanation point.
GF.
GL, no, GFL.
GFL 2NV.
Alright.
I'm going to do my last pull.
Are you guys ready?
Are you guys ready, guys?
Actually, Snuffy, you should do more.
Well, I feel like I can stall a lot longer.
I'm seeing if I can do, like, a multi-pool, maybe.
You're going to do a multi-pool?
You're going to pull more than once?
I think I can do that if I'm smart, but I don't know.
I'm going to enter my own giveaway again.
I'm kind of tempted.
We master of stalling.
Stuffy still has three more.
I'm waiting for you.
I have one.
I got it.
Don't worry, guys.
Don't worry.
All right.
I'm going to pull my last one, Stuffy.
Okay, okay, okay.
Cardboard.
Oh, right.
the last one congratulations john concord congratulations oh
hey you got a john too wait what really yeah did you say
john clog clog word
i got cardboard cardboard one i said john concord i was
thinking the guy who won oh yeah see that's a thing
congratulations john clogs words okay another person won
eridan eridan underscore underscores specifically thank you
congratulations i'm going to try my best to do a
multi-person one how much more do you have left i just
finished five three three more so i will let me see
i'm just chilling waiting for her to you know by the time
you figure out get three you could How do I you pull it one
by one?
You just re-roll it.
What do you mean?
Oh, you don't use Nightbot, do you?
No!
Oh, okay, yeah, I can't help you.
I can't help you with that.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm gonna try again.
I was just like, oh yeah, nah.
Nah, nah, I was like, wait, why are you struggling?
I was so confused.
I was like, just pull for it, forehead.
Okay.
5,000 trash tokens.
That's not right.
Are you okay?
No, no, no!
Like, what are you talking about?
You don't wanna...
I don't know, we should just combine our chats.
I'm gonna...
I would just keep doing it.
I would just keep doing the first one.
Multiple tokens ended.
Come over here.
I'm knocking.
Let's stream it together.
Okay.
Oh, wait, yeah.
Oh, forgot about that.
Yeah, or yeah, chat shout, and I'll interact with each
other.
Knock, knock.
Wait, is that how you do it?
Collaboration?
I've never done this before.
You have to, like, link me, though, I think.
I have to link you?
Let me check my, like, Twitch notifications.
How do I actually...
This is my first tab.
Why is there, like, a Discord call?
Oh, here we go.
Oh.
We have, like, a little Discord call, too.
What is this?
Wait, have you never done this?
No, bro, I'm not on Twitch.
What do you mean?
You're literally on Twitch all the time.
That is not true.
Don't lie to yourself.
You played Marvel Rivals.
That is not, that is true.
But the last time I played Rivals was a while ago on stream.
I played it off stream yesterday.
Yeah, that is a long time.
That is a long time.
Okay, I'm not even in here.
Oh, there you are.
Oh, guys, look.
Look, you're gonna, guys.
Wait, this is gonna make it even more confusing with you.
Yeah, we're integrating with Snuffy's chat.
Say hi to Snuffy's chat.
Wait, guys, don't get chat.
Don't steal my raffle.
Guys, enter Snuffy's raffle too.
If you didn't win, you can enter her raffle now.
That's right.
We york, yeah, we're yorking your community's raffle now.
We're gonna york your tickets.
Wait, wait, I think my group one pulled five at once.
wait I got it we have that's right take her raffle too I got
Hanabihuni at last tech technical and dr. base face you guys
thank you congratulations on your freebies expect mysterious
message from a stranger Denny Dragoon took her took one of
her raffles just just lie and say you're you're just a you
just have two Oshis this is just you just you're dual
streaming you're doing yeah don't admit to anything don't
talk to strangers all right now that the raffle is done we
can we can move on to more of the anniversary stuff i want
to never mind wait wait no what are you no no no no come on
tell me what you're gonna say Huh?
What are you gonna say?
No, I was just gonna say that I want to...
Yeah?
I can't, though.
No, no, I don't remember.
What do you want to say?
Say it, Snuffy.
There's just...
My character, when you go to her closet or whatever, she
just breathes really heavy onto something.
I just want to comment on that.
I'm just going to make a comment.
Okay, so...
She's got like kite bombs.
We're going to go to the crew deck zone now.
uh we want to let you guys know there are some special
interactions related to the first year anniversary and
makiato makita i can't pronounce sorry i'm really bad
pronouncing names uh makiatos makiatos can i have a one
grande machiato please wait whoa i'm a guy i'm like i'm like
john chad
is interactive story is available for free now and that
players can earn up to 35 outfit access permissions 15 of
which will be sent via in-game mail between november 22nd to
december 1st so make sure to check your mail guys anyway
we're going into the cruise deck now i'm in i'm in raptured
by this place the crew deck the crew deck well you're
already in i okay yeah we have to do clue for the fans.
Wait, I am a guy too.
Oh my god, there is, bro, too.
There is a coffee shop.
Wait, I gotta get tea first.
This character, Peridia, I really like that.
Wait, wait, before we go to Kluca, I gotta buy, I gotta buy
today's special.
What does that do?
It's a ginger, I don't know, but I gotta get my grinding
Machiavelli.
Can I like change your character?
Who am I?
You're literally him.
Wait, she's making me coffee.
Wait, let us make a coffee.
Yeah, that's what I'm getting.
Or Lava.
Which one am I?
I forget.
Today's special.
Well, we're going to have a chat about, I can't wait.
Oh, she wants to talk to me.
About movies?
Okay, let's talk about her interest.
Since the first time we fought together, it's been about 10
years.
I'm drinking my drink.
Oh, you get to know more about her.
Hey.
Hey, girl.
every mouthful tastes like bliss
i would have voiced i'm the man i bet i could do that yeah
yeah my wait what's your character mine's brian his name is
brian what is blake why do we both just do that there would
be blake and brian we sound like a dangerous duo where the
heck is clue guy i gotta talk to it we're trying to find
clue guy Oh, there's her bike.
Oh my god, there's the fridge.
Where's Klu-Kai?
Wait, where is she?
Wait, was she serving...
Was your character serving drinks?
We need to find the pool.
Uh, what?
Talk to...
Okay, no.
We gotta go to the pool.
Call of a hair accessory?
Where's the pool?
Yeah, Brian has no ass, unfortunately.
I thought I would sit on this bike, but...
I just sat next to it.
I don't see Klu-Kai, but I'm gonna talk to Peru.
Aridia, she's nice.
Wait, I think I found...
Wait, actually, no, that's not the pool.
There's the armory.
Oh, that's cool.
This is new.
The crew deck.
Oh, it's in the wreck room.
We have to go to the wreck room.
What are these, like, envelopes?
Why does it say it costs two envelopes to proceed to talk to
this character?
Should I get them?
I don't know.
They just...
They want, like, letters and stuff, I guess.
Oh, my God.
Wait, there's a lucky gotcha?
Guys, I gotta do this.
Oh, it took me to the wreck room.
Oh, my God!
I already have that.
I don't need it.
I were nerdy lucky enough.
I think I lost.
I think I'm off track.
Yeah, yeah.
I think you're okay.
I got to a pool.
Okay.
All right.
No, no, no.
Okay.
I'm waiting for you.
I'm in the wreck room.
I'm just with another woman.
I'm with another individual.
No, you gotta go outside.
You go outside and then you see her at sunbathing.
And then did you see this?
Torino stares at me with her hetachromatic gaze.
Okay, are you ready?
I gave Peridia my money and now she's...
Why did you give her your money?
Because I love her.
You just met her!
She's so good.
You literally just met her.
She's so perfect.
These are perfect enough.
Oh my god, cool guys.
I've been waiting for you for a very long time.
Okay, I'm sorry.
Oh, so you're no better than me.
No, no, no.
doing my thing I said we gotta do Klukai and I'm doing my
Klukai and I found Pyrrhia you want to change to continue
how do you get to the wreck room now for real though what do
you mean there's a sign that says I'm literally changing I'm
changing the world's time oh my god you're missing out
you're missing out right now I gotta remove you from this
scene I gotta remove you am I covering it up yeah you're
covering there you go I just gauge from your guys' chat
what's possibly going on right now.
Yeah, it's right.
Stuffy's chat missing out.
Unextra- okay.
Wait, should I just keep giving Peridia money and try to get
like something just as good?
She's not even part of the event.
Bro, she's not- Yes, Clu-Kai is!
Wait, where is she?
Okay.
Wait, which one is Clu-Kai?
She's the one outside the pool.
She's no when you're at the point you'll know which one's
glue guy Chad I'm lost oh she splashed soda in my eye but
it's okay Oh oh touch touch where you're missing out man.
Oh my god I'm literally applying sunscreen right now.
What are you doing still giving money to her still giving
money to Peridia Where's glue guy where which one is I
didn't even have to do this for I didn't have to pay for it.
Why won't you let me do that with you?
Let's see what let's do press M press M for fast travel a
helping hand.
Whoa No, no, not now
Well, it's like I've guys it's like I'm applying the
sunscreen by my myself to Dude, look at that.
Look at my cursor.
It's so immersive, guys.
I'm customizing my house right now.
What?
I don't know.
How do I apply sunscreen?
I'm doing furniture.
We're doing a furniture.
It's so cute though.
Look at that.
Wait, can I do more?
This game is good as heck.
Yeah.
Whoa!
You're like changing all the furniture here.
You're flying, you're doing furniture.
I'm trying to find the wreck room.
I just want to go to the wreck room.
Just looking at furniture right now.
Somebody please have like he's lost.
Wait, unforeseen development.
Whoa!
Oh, oh, okay, okay, okay.
Here's the wreck room.
There you go.
Oh my gosh, she's gonna drown me.
Oh my god, she actually drowned.
Okay, Kukai tried to drown me.
What is happening?
Oh no, I'm pretending to be drowning so I get CP.
Oh my god.
I'm so smart.
Is this Kukai?
I'm confused.
I don't see her anymore.
She's the one on the bench.
You know, with her asses out.
That is someone and now they're showing me like their VR
headset.
Okay, so, so, oh my god, I'm actually a genius.
I literally pretended to drown so I can get CPR.
god that is like that isn't cpr like extremely painful
people like break their ribs on cpi you risk everything no
it's okay it's okay that's the risk i'm willing to take
that's the risk i'm willing to choose how long you want to
spend with me did you is this what you did a kiss is like 15
minutes it's you go to dual dual set whisper no i don't want
to do oh my god i'm i'm so locked right now something is
happening oh did you are you there are you there are you
there are you understand now do you i think i'm in vr with
my with my with where are you what well right now i'm in a
bed to get oh she's pulling me into the bed with her
sunscreen what oh my god oh my god you found the asmr
section where did you go there's only one person out here
she's gonna he's she took me here for 15 minutes for 15
minutes she's keeping me here you're like 50 minutes in
heaven i paid her i paid her to let me into this vr
experience for what you were doing with your money with the
devs money no this was free oh wait i wait i see it wait did
you talk to macchiato or was it dreamscape which one go gozo
gozo i don't groza groza
you're drunk already what will i do with you oh gosh groza i
don't know I think she's doing ASMR right here like the like
rubbing like the you know what ASMR is like wait wait who is
the girl who's the girl is she purple hair or no her name is
Groza she's blonde oh oh you got oh that's not the right I
found my key I don't know she's rubbing my ears oh my god
get me out of here get me out of here I'm okay okay I love
it I love it my VR experience.
See, I have Machiano and Crowley.
Where is...
Where is... Oh my god, you can do 120 minutes of this?
Hopping this bubble wrap is so comfy.
Okay, go downstairs.
Okay, Snuffy, go downstairs, and then there's a door to...
That's a Terrence.
You go outside, and you see the girl sitting on the chair
with her ass out.
Talk to her.
You're just saying things.
Like, okay, you go downstairs.
You literally went upstairs to the VR room.
What do you do?
You had to go up the stairs to access the VR!
Go to the terrace!
Where?
The terrace?
Okay, it's uh...
Oh my god, are all these... are all they... are they all
available?
Yes.
Oh, I want this one.
Vepley.
She looks cute.
Curious logging.
I like how you talk to everyone but Klukei.
Wait, they have, this one pays, I pay two coins.
Stop paying the money to do it for free!
Okay, okay, is it Dolchit Whisper or do I just talk to
Klukei?
The Dolchit Whisper is the Dolchit Whisper.
There was another character with Dolchit Whisper though.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, that's true.
That's true.
No, no, there's a Ulrid.
Ulrid also has Dolchit Whisper.
Should I see what that's about?
Is that, are they both the event?
No, it's Kukai and Machiavelli.
I'm trying to remember.
Oh, here's $2.
Okay, now I'm giving her $2, too.
I gave Machiavelli $2.
Wait, you, but you yelled at me saying I can't give her $2.
Yeah, but she's part of the event, Snuffy.
It's in our briefing.
We have to give her money.
You gave, you were giving random people money.
I just, like, I just, I just, I just wanted everybody to
prosper.
The Klukai!
Oh my god.
Girl, don't you know it's November?
Put on some clothes?
I'm feeling relaxed and tipsy.
Oh my god, I just offered her a drink.
Happy Thanksgiving, Klukai.
Makiado shows me a list of stuff.
Oh, she's, I'm furniture shopping with Makiado.
Sabi is to test you.
I'm trying to find a dulcet whisper for her but I think I
have to pay her Machiavelli mini grabs my arms oh it's soda
this is like a child she was like oh I'm getting so turned
off this and then it's like she's like oh wait this is soda
you gave me soda like she's being fake drunk what did I just
hand her and I'm like TV oh okay Where's the TV?
This is my tincture.
I created this.
My concoction.
How do I act, guys?
How do I activate the...
Oh.
Mischievous help.
Ooh.
I'm giving her mischievous help.
Why are her hands so detailed?
Oh, you'll know why.
Okay, I'm doing macchiatas.
So...
I'll wait for you before I start.
Boo.
I'll wait for you before I start it.
Okay.
Oh, are you rubbing it?
Are you rubbing?
I'm caressing.
Yeah, you caressing.
Oh, you got the feet off.
Which one did you break?
Oh, you freak.
You're right.
I, you know, guys, I got, you know, my child be like, boo,
you're safe.
You're so safe.
I got it.
Thank you, girls, front line for the sponsor.
When you click the inner thigh ops.
Oh, you freak.
I clicked the back.
I didn't know that it was like.
I didn't know that it was like dependent on what area you
are.
I know what you are, fluffy.
Is that why is that why you're a new elf your beat your new
outfit has no shoes?
No, cuz you wouldn't wear shoes in the beach.
I'm wearing shoes.
I'm wearing crocs.
What are you talking about?
Those are good.
I'm wearing crocs So it's like she there's different routes
you can go so it's like she's getting paid for this.
I'm jealous
Wait, who's next to come here.
I go to the TV at the bottom You go to the giant, you see
the giant TV.
Yeah.
I think...
Yeah, you see the TV.
And then you click Dolce Wessper on the TV.
Or on her.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I'm doing it with you.
I clicked it.
And then she's on that couch, right, with her feet out, with
her grippers out.
No, she's wearing tights.
Yeah, but her grippers are technically out.
If you were paying attention to that, they would be...
They're technically not out.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Snuffy is technically hiding the grippers, so can you move a
little to the right?
Can you move a little to the right?
Snuffy just tilt a little.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let me just, let me just...
Okay, so now I'm paranoid of where I'm going to click, and
now Chad is going to judge me if I click anywhere.
No, you can't.
You guys do go with your instinct.
You're thinking too hard.
We gotta know what your...
your real reactions are.
We're not getting away so easily.
Why?
Oh, come and sit down?
Whoa!
Yo, she just...
Oh, she has nice nails.
Distraction.
What did you do?
you press.
I picked hand in hand.
Oh, you just held her hand?
Yeah, I kind of wanted to do the brow option, though.
Oh, coward.
Oh, I held her hand.
I'm holding her hand right now.
Oh, my God.
Before marriage?
Touch.
Hand holding.
Oh,
you don't like this movie?
We can watch something else, girl.
You heard of Netflix and chill?
But she just stares at you, you shouldn't care.
She's not even watching the movie.
Yeah, yeah, you're not even watching the movie.
What's the point?
Her eyes haven't even turned a little bit to the TV.
She's only focused on us.
She wants to look at it.
What the heck?
Oh wait, it is a horror film.
What?
What's up?
It's literally the shining, isn't it?
You're the twins.
Little tees.
Comforting words are there.
What would you say?
What'd you pick?
I took, I little tees.
What about you?
Little tees.
Oh, I didn't even see that option.
Oh, I made sure to see that.
I'm teasing here.
I'm doing its itsy bitsy spider.
Touch.
Oh, touch.
Yeah, I got that touch.
Touch.
I'd like to touch.
Okay.
Yeah.
Um, the touch icon was on the face.
Why was it on the shoulder?
It's not what I sign up for.
See no evil.
Hear no.
Timely warning.
Let's do... I'm going to do what you're going to do.
I'm going to do hear no evil.
I'll do see no evil.
I'll cover your eyes.
I'll cover your ears.
I am so detailed.
I've got nice fingernails.
Don't worry.
I just don't hear the scary jumping.
I'm scared, so it won't matter.
Yeah.
Well, what did you get?
What are you?
I got her slapping her boobs on my face.
What?
Dang.
What did you?
I got scammed.
I should have been hearing.
I won.
Okay, who next?
Can I do this again?
Can I just...
I'm going back to the VR.
You want to do it?
It's just...
Can I do this again?
You like retried.
Didn't get the booze option.
Apparently you can decorate your crew deck.
How did you- I was doing.
How did you customize it?
Press F4, I think?
F4, what?
What?
Is that not what it is?
What do you mean?
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
I'm glad you're going to say alt F4.
Yeah, just press F4.
Oh,
I could change, like, the fridge.
Oh, the Galaxy fridge is pretty cool.
I like the Galaxy fridge.
They have Galaxy TV.
How do you get $25?
Dang.
Gotta make those girls work it.
I want to get a lot of different things.
Oh, my God.
Wait, I can show, like, a Zen garden, too.
Wait, I have an aquarium.
Wait, what?
Wait, do I have enough money for this?
Okay, I'm going to put an aquarium in here.
Oh, I see.
Confirmed.
Oh, there's like a cat tower.
Oh, you can craft stuff or something.
Yeah, I put in an aquarium.
There's a capybara.
Wait, there is?
Where is it?
I don't, I could not explain how to get there.
Yeah, there's like...
I do not see the capybara option.
like furniture layout, ornament layout, theme layout.
If you click ornament layout and you click like, you click
where it says like one or two on the screen, gives you like
little ornaments you can place down.
Oh, that's cute.
Oh, yeah, the laptop.
You can display your figures and stuff.
I can display my laptop, guys.
Kurios.
I don't put that here.
That's cute.
These are cute.
This game is kind of amazing.
There's a lot of stuff you can do here.
I just want to go back to the VRS.
You can add different dolls, too, if you want here, too.
I love the cat tower, mapping the cat tower.
My girls are going to love this.
I love the cat tower.
First, I can't theme layout.
Oh, oh, I could decorate a theme to it, too.
Yeah, there's a lot of stuff you can do.
Oh, my God.
I put the cat tower up here and all the women, like, All the
women.
They came up here.
They knew they were like, ooh, kitty.
Meow, meow.
So which one of you wants to get in VR?
Oh, I'm making them make food for me.
That's right.
Cook for Brian.
How do you do that?
Oh, my name is Blake.
How do you cook food for me?
That's right.
I just recruited Lena and I'm like, cook for me.
Oh my God, what?
Cook for me.
Cook for Brian.
How do you raise your bunny?
Yummy, yummy.
It tastes pretty.
If I say okay, then she'll strive to make it better.
See, I'll try making it even tastier next time, guys.
I told her it's just all right, and then she'll try for
something better.
It's just all right.
That's terrible.
Don't, no, she was like, I'll make sure to make it even
better next time, and I'm like, good.
good try harder i gave her a thumbs up after too i spent two
coins i don't think i've got this woman to make food for me
also cardboard mike and kreitzer remember to respond let uh
open dm so uh silent band bandito can send you the code for
your free stuff let's do the sunscreen again
I wonder how to make them make food for you.
You go back to the main lobby, like the front air.
And then there's like a, you saw the, there's a delicious
cuisine and you click that.
Gotcha, gotcha.
Oh, I can put stickers too.
Oh, that's cute.
I'm going to put stickers on my favorite girls.
I like that one.
Delicious cuisine.
Yeah, and then make the new girl cook food for you.
The new girl.
All right, you girl.
Time for you to pass the test.
The cuisine.
okay guys while we wait for oh she looks upset why girl what
is that there's purple fumes coming from it she's gonna
craft me poison damage she was not she literally crafted me
poison damage what is wrong with did yours actually make
something good is mine made like something that's it got
censored she made a delicious I'm doing the ASMR while
you're here or you're cooking Don't eat that.
Don't eat that.
Poor thing.
My once keen sense of taste loses its functionality.
She just made me poison.
Bro, what the fuck?
I got a great experience.
I'm getting the best parts of this sponsee.
I'm gonna have to tell her that this was barely edible
because she literally crafted me like straight poison.
Oh my god.
I'm doing the ASMR right now.
I'm doing the ASMR.
Oh, my God.
Did you get to pick who you did?
No, it's Groza.
I think it's a Groza experience.
For 15!
Oh, my God.
There was a 120 minutes option, too.
What if, like, I do an ASMR stream where I just boot this
up?
And then I put...
And then...
And then stuffy...
I put my PNG, my face on top of her.
And...
You sign up for the one hour special.
Yeah.
Wait, she has a lease.
Oh my god.
I can't have another drink.
I'm sorry.
You not have another food?
much tea time it says one out of one but it says i've
already drunk today you just had you had too much today your
chat just says your belt was untone what is going on guys
was just leading me around to random locations where the
heck are you going i don't know stuffy move i can't at sea
oh there's an arcade machine
skip i want to know about the arcade machine oh there's
actual arcade games oh it's like from all the other games we
many games we played before that's cool i put memories on my
wall which are like chapters of the story i think you yeah
like the official art and stuff that's cool that's cute you
can press v for oh v for free oh i didn't know that
apparently you can free cam the asmr section you can free
cam in general i'm like in the rec room and i'm just free
camming wait really oh yeah oh that's cool you're just like
a gold like a ghost spooking around
Someone said free cam on your stream.
What are you doing?
I was looking at her eyes.
Don't even let chat.
What are you doing?
No, why are they saying free cam?
I was looking directly into her eyes.
Who are you looking at?
Who was it?
Yeah.
Don't even know her name.
That's messed up.
You don't even know her name And you were freaky here I just
couldn't remember I know him I just couldn't remember it
Sure You just happened to not remember My beloved Paradia
What do you want with me?
Dolcet Whisper?
You too?
Hey guys You guys thought I was gonna do something else With
the free camp But I'm here to look at something else Wait I
think I can I just think I unlocked Another Another Dolchit
Whisper.
Wait, who?
Who's?
Oh, no, that's the ASMR.
That's ASMR.
Oh, I think she just told me about it.
She just told me the tutorial about Dolchit Whisper.
Oh.
Freaking teased me.
Can we have a crumb of the...
We had ASMR, Metti.
Is that not enough?
so this is the greed they talk about how many more how many
more dulcet whispers can i get how do i do that i mean you
could replay it you can unlock the other ones because how do
you unlock the other ones you replay it you replay it to get
the oh i think they're different characters no no no this is
the green this is the men's greed i need more i need more
dulcet whispers
no the feet were pink we can't even talk yeah you can't
honestly yeah you there's no reason i know there's no reason
for me to do it again but no guys why just go back to the
dreamscape sorry everyone i'm just this is what the future
warned us about i'm just locked in vr i don't want to do
anything else just listen to vr asmr see you later everybody
girls front line too for sponsoring us we it's been it's
been a joy experiencing the first year anniversary today um
and for you know i tell me did you have fun time checking
out girls front line too for the first time i want to play
it a lot i just want to talk to all the other girls now
you're just like i want to know more about you yeah i need
dulcet whisper with peridia what why is it What does she
have on you?
The cat, she's like a kitty.
She's a cute kitty.
I don't even like, I don't even know where she, I don't
think I even have her on my team.
I don't have Peridia.
No way.
She's got like a cat tail.
Yeah, I don't have a cat here.
Oh, you're missing a peak then.
I'm sorry.
Aria can be cleaned up.
Is it telling you that for you?
What?
I gotta clean this place.
these women are what are you doing it to your place i'm
cleaning it guys where is paridia chat please show her
paridia where is she i don't even know oh she was on the
boat i have a boat what how do you get a boat i don't know
to be fair i think we are on the boat so that's like oh she
was on the pool side sorry like clue kai was there i wasn't
paying attention to anybody else nice she's amazing you're
gonna see her and you're gonna be like clue kai who bro she
let you rub her feet what are you talking about and so will
paridia once i dedicate enough love and time to her boy she
doesn't even let you do anything what's so good about
paridia she doesn't even let you do anything you have to
spend more time with her just do free care Everything you
could ever need is just off the bat.
That's right.
You mean just sitting there?
She's just sitting there on the couch with me.
Guys, Doki can't appreciate the fighter things.
We get it.
What were you doing with Klu-Kai?
Not Klu-Kai, Peridia.
What were you doing?
She was just sitting on the couch.
Don't you see me have matching eyeballs?
It's like destiny.
You know, it was romantic.
Yeah, you looked into your eyes and she just stared into the
distance.
yeah yeah so what if she had a few idle animations she's
programmed to do that i wasn't looking no no no no no wait
who are anybody want to get a massage i feel like just
running around this ship like anybody want to get rubbed all
over you want to anyway guys if you want to check out more
of grunts i feel like i think stuff is going to be here
forever My name is Blake.
Yeah, Blake's gonna start living here soon.
Wait, select Delta O.
What?
Joki, did you know you can walk around this, Klukei?
Wait, what?
Press P. Press P. Oh my god, wait, I'm hurt.
Wait, I could...
Can I massage myself?
Wait, I need a note.
Are we creating a paradox right now?
Me and Klu-Kai?
Oh, no, it's not.
It's just a...
It's not Klu-Kai's hat.
It doesn't matter.
Are you going to talk to people as Klu-Kai?
Oh, no.
You, like, turn to the man.
I unlock the self-love mode.
Yeah, this is self-love.
Look at me, girl.
Self-love mode.
Boo.
I can't self-love myself.
I can't give myself a myself...
massage what's the point yeah i can't if you do free cam you
can't even look at yourself it's so sad but if you guys want
to check out more on the first year anniversary please feel
free to click on the link pinned in the chat and in our
panels it does help support the stream a lot and uh also uh
the sponsor as well uh but yes there's a lot of things to
check up for the year anniversary everyone so like i said
there is 130 plus plus 13 000 plus collapse pieces and free
outfits everything for free and we all love free stuff also
you get to talk to clue kai what's more to add sophie are
you okay i think i got put into a trance the game is so good
i got put into a yeah i just saw you're like this don't
forget you can play as clue kai you don't just you don't
just experience it you get to be her you get to be clue kai
and you're fully customized room.
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
And thank you again, Girls Frontline 2, for the sponsor, for
sponsoring both of us.
Happy anniversary, everyone, to Girls Frontline 2.
I know, it's crazy.
So you've enjoyed, you definitely, I know for sure Snuffy
enjoyed her first time playing.
She didn't even get to the real part of the game.
I mean, not to like glaze.
I didn't expect like full 3D unique animations and stuff.
I had never played this game.
So this was like you know this isn't the actual game, right?
this is just like the side stuff because it said something
about the tiles when you like get different items and stuff
so yeah this is like this is just like the this is this all
new though for the anniversary but this is like the you know
the lore stuff like you get to know more about the girls and
everything so you're not even playing the actual game stuffy
I think this is your game though this I think this is all I
need to play the game yeah this is all you need extra
features this is this is amazing we're playing it right
hello ladies I mean thank you for the sponsor whoa whoa oh
my god you can look at you can look at Klukei while you are
Klukei isn't that I know right but sadly you can't give
yourself some self love unfortunately you got we got to
invite brian and blake over for that i'm just admiring the
characters okay
again thank you everyone for watching thank you girls
frontline too for the sponsor it was a pleasure checking out
the first year anniversary make sure i hope you guys got
your twitch drops for those who have linked their accounts
uh to twitch i hope you guys enjoy all the stuff from the
twitch drops and also everyone that won the giveaway codes
um yeah it also says if you download the game with our link
it says that you get over 130 pools which is like what 13
000 like units or like currency uh co-ops pieces you get
chiu chiu chiu chiu chiu ha yeah you have dragon chef
outfits you get all that i think yep so make sure to click
for real yeah so make sure to click the link uh the link
that's pinned in our chat and in our panel and then you can
download the game yourself to grab all the free stuff and
also explore um explore the crew deck yourself as well and
interact with the girls too uh man thank you stuffy i hope
you had a great time with the sponsor today with me yes
thank you dokey this was awesome thank you for teaching me
too thank you for leading me around of course of course i
know it's like your first time playing it so made sure to
you know last time yeah yeah literally like into the vr yes
support like yeah first time i was like go we gotta find
kluka and the snuffy gets herself in some asmr shit like i
was like snuffy this was not part of our uh i'm sorry i got
to rail i didn't know what was happening but this is a good
feature and then she started giving her money away to random
girls and i'm like Luke guy.
Stop giving your money to random women.
Do not leave you on the streets.
I cannot be trusted with money.
Do not not leave her on the streets with beautiful women.
I cannot be trusted.
I'm easily persuaded and distracted.
Are you going to be still streaming Snuffy?
Yeah, I think I'm going to stream just a little bit longer.
I'll send you over a raid.
I'm going to call it here, everyone.
But yeah, I'm going to them over to you oh thank you bye bye
thank you guys thank you doki chat thank you guys yeah for
the sponsor bye bye bye uh that was fun i had a great time
with snuffy um this was her oh she's big now because i
wanted to use uh we're not hiding anything anymore um but
yeah it was a great time um doing a sponsor snuffy uh i was
told by uh that she hasn't done a lot of sponsors before um
i mean she does do spot a lot of sponsors but like she
hasn't done as many as i have uh over a couple of years uh
i've been doing this so um i did my best to try and help
guide her along um throughout it and i hope she had a great
time and i hope she enjoys this game um so and share chat
yeah i know but we're rating her anyway so it's fine um but
anyway anyway thank you again for the sponsor girls front
line too um happy anniversary it's always a pleasure um
checking out your games every update and thank you for
always sponsoring me and also including Snuffy along as the
as my duo partner for this one holy camera I know you're
welcome guys happy anniversary as always everybody stay
hydrated posture check get up and move around to get that
blood flow and if you suffer me head to bed cause you
deserve it I'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys
bye Yeah.